[Musique]
c'est au coeur de la maison triolet
aragon à saint-arnoult-en-yvelines que
les amoureux d'art et de littérature ont
rendez-vous autographes une exposition
qui regroupe street art fresque éphémère
et poésie tout ça réalisé par l'artiste
c215 alias christian guémy d'abord vous
dire qu'on met très heureux d'accueillir
cette exposition 7,215 parce que 215
était un grand artiste qu à une action
internationale mais qui est très lié au
monde de la poésie la littérature voix
dont une mise en examen on nous avait
beaucoup de chance dans les rues de
paris rome londres são paulo c215 a
réalisé de nombreux portraits de figures
littéraires à travers le monde entier
les visiteurs découvrent ainsi les
traits de paul verlaine arthur rimbaud
ou encore victor hugo
[Musique]
donc là on a donc des photographies de
grands poètes qui ont deux romancières
parfois je vois ici qui ont été réalisés
dans la rue là par exemple vous avez
aimé césaire qu'on retrouve là on peut
voir aussi des textes de célèbres
écrivains c'est ce dialogue entre images
et mots que l'artiste a voulu
retranscrire qu'est ce qu'on voit ici eh
bien on voit une série de textes c'est
très émouvant de les voir ici ont des
textes de grands poètes qui ont été
écrits par eux-mêmes dans des textes
autographes donc là par exemple on a un
texte un grand ami d'aragon qui est venu
ici plusieurs fois qu'est donc pas les
lois par exemple ici écrit à la main et
en regard de ces textes vous avez le
portrait que proposent ces 215 de chacun
de ces grands poètes qui formeront
panthéon un peu personnel dans cette
exposition c215 propose une large
palette de ses capacités artistiques
après ces oeuvres réalisées dans la rue
les visiteurs peuvent découvrir une
sculpture de louis aragon en deux
dimensions ou contempler un portrait de
sa mère réalisé sur un vitrail le clou
de l'exposition cette immense fresque
éphémère des deux écrivains elsa triolet
et louis aragon conçu spécialement pour
l'occasion exactement une oeuvre
éphémère qui a été réalisé pour cette
exposition on est très heureux donc où
on retrouve une main en aragon d'un côté
elsa triolet de l'autre cette oeuvre
sera visible jusqu'au 8 mai date de la
fin de l'exposition c'est aussi
l'occasion de visiter ou de revisiter la
maison des deux écrivains elsa triolet
et louis aragon dans ce magnifique écrin
de verdure